Dans cette vidéo, cette fois-ci,
on va se focaliser sur l'analyse rétorique,
raisonnement et dialectique
de la candidate renaissance,
Valérie ayet, qui se présente aux élections européennes.
Et faut-il se préparer à faire la guerre ?
Ma réponse à la François Gaëlle belami, elle est claire,
la position du
président de la République
sur la question de la dissuasion nucléaire,
c'est rien de 9 sous le soleil.
Non, c'est pas très clair Valérie.
Et pour preuve, Valérie,
je vais prendre cet
article qui date du 19/02 deux-mille-vingt-trois.
Emmanuel Macron nous disait
à l'époque qu'il fallait faire attention
pour ne pas écraser les Russes. Is
It
also ?
D'abord,
Emmanuel Macron est-il en train de plomber l'écologie ?
Moi, j'assume pas. Le vert,
c'est notre bilan,
c'est de permettre à nos enfants de jouer
avec des jouets qui ne sont pas toxiques.
Le pacte vert, c'est de s'assurer que demain matin,
quand on tartine les les
les tartines de Nutella de nos enfants,
et bien. Euh, le Nutella n'aura pas été
produit en dévastant des
forêts à l'autre bout du monde.
C'est la fin de notre absolessance programmée.
Les fameuses machines à la vie de nos grand-mères,
euh, qui fonctionnait pendant 25 ans.
Vous étiez à théorie sur la remise en
cause de l'ambition globale.
L'ambition, elle est toujours là.
Là, on est tombé sur 1 pépite.
Ce que l'on va faire, c'est que l'on va ralentir 1 peu,
on va observer le raisonnement
et voir ce qu'il contient réellement.
Donc déjà,
commençons par La prémise majeure qui va être
annoncée par la
présentatrice
d'un autre défi pour l'Europe,
celui de la transition écologique.
la transition écologique doit-elle rester prioritaire ?
L'Union européenne s'est fixée 1 cap,
la neutralité carbone
d'ici deux-mille-cinquante.
Cela implique
notamment la fin
des moteurs thermiques en deux-mille-trente-cinq.
Maintenant que vous êtes professionnels du raisonnement,
vous savez comment ça fonctionne. La prémisse majeure,
la prémisse mineure.
Et ensuite la conclusion et la représentation mentale.
La prémisse majeure commence par la
transition écologique,
doit-elle rester prioritaire,
avec Le Cap de
neutralité carbone en deux-mille-cinquante
et la fin de moteur
thermique en deux-mille-trente-cinq
comme prévu par l'Union européenne ?
Et ce que nous répond en 1ère spinner Valérie,
c'est l'ambition du pacte vert,
ça, de permettre à nos enfants de jouer
avec les jouets qui ne sont pas toxiques
et que nos tartines de Nutella soient mangées
avec la conscience
que l'on n'a pas dévasté des forêts
ailleurs dans le monde,
et de mettre fin à l'obsécence programmée
de la machine à laver de nos mémés,
on va tous mourir, on va tous mourir.
Non, non, vous ne rêvez pas. La conclusion, c'est bien,
l'ambition, est toujours là.
Voyons voir ce que ça fait la représentation mentale,
on voit bien la transition écologique
qui est priorité à Polonie européenne. Let
me
see
Valérie yes a bu,
bien évidemment sur le registre du logos
et sur 1 soi-disant etos,
donc l'éthique et la morale éthique,
pour le fait que nos enfants ne puissent pas avoir.
Des jouets toxiques,
bien évidemment, on ne détruit pas l'environnement.
La forme qu'elle prend,
c'est bien évidemment démonstrative.
Malheureusement pour le charisme, c'est 0.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut observer de Valérie
et quelle est sa dialectique ?
Bah c'est la dialectique au fond,
c'est juste de nous prendre pour des cons.
Sa stratégie c'est donc infantiliser les gens
et on le voit lorsqu'elle parle de clarté et de Macron.
Euh, c'est 1 bel oxymort
ha ha. Ensuite,
lorsqu'on lui parle de la transition écologique,
de l'action de l'Union européenne,
elle nous parle de tartine de Nutella.
Infantiser les autres,
c'est 1 manière de dominer en se mettant dans 1
position d'autorité.
Donc la stratégie est tout simplement de montrer
que les autres sont au fond bêtes
et que j'ai raison
et de toute façon
ça n'a pas d'importance
parce que que j'ai raison ou tort,
le peuple de toute façon peut lui mentir
aujourd'hui, puis demain il oubliera.
Et c'est exactement ce que font les parents
lorsqu'ils infantilisent leurs enfants
sous prétexte qu'ils ne sont pas adultes,
ils leur racontent des histoires sur la petite souris
et pareil pour le Père Noël
en sachant que pertinemment qu'ils mentent
et de toute façon ça n'a pas d'importance,
ce qui compte c'est de savoir que l'enfant est content
et quand il saura la vérité,
ben il finira par l'oublier.
Donc finalement
les macronistes
sont juste des enfants qui se vengent de leurs parents
ha ha ha ha. Bref, est-ce qu'on va tous mourir ?
Oui mais. Pas tout de suite !
N'oubliez jamais, camarade,
tout ce que vous apprenez à vos enfants,
ils vous le font payer plus tard !
Ha ha ha ! Gloire à la Chine ! Vive la Chine !
Elle seul ne ment pas !
Vive mon camarade !